hi everybody
questions yeah back here hi all the way
back here Tiffani Tyler how are you good
thank you so slated when you did that
show that night and it was hard to
believe that you were actually the first
african-american woman to host SNL I
can't believe that I was the first
african-american woman I was the first
african-american female stand-up
comedian thank you for correcting that
yeah all of that being said what is that
meant to you and it seems after that
your career just took off well I first
off it felt really good second I was
super surprised as well I was doing my
research when I found out they wanted me
to host I was doing my research and I
wanted to ask advice from other women
who've done it and I was looking for
other female comics who've done it that
I can relate to and I couldn't find any
and I even called Whoopi Goldberg was
like okay so tell me what it's like she
was like [ __ ] you too first I was like
what and so that was super cool and then
the actual experience of it was it was
it was hard at first because I had came
in with all these ideas but this is a
machine that's been happening and I had
to like let go and let them guide me and
I just made sure my monologue was on
point because I'm a stand-up comedian
first and I just needed to make sure
that was the main thing and and I did
that and I feel like to answer your
other question saying that my careers
started taking off after that girl my
career had took off when I got on stage
the first time because I knew I was
gonna be something I just didn't know
how long it would take me and it's been
almost 20 years so yeah yes yes hi
Tiffany Abbey with People magazine huh
gratulations
opening was great with all the talk of
diversity and how it's the most diverse
group of nominees ever but Twitter right
now kind of seems to have a backlash
about how there have been only white
winners tonight and how we still have so
far to go and there were so many
wonderful
actors and writers and all of the
different categories that were nominated
do you have any thoughts of how we kind
of get to that next hurdle girl no I'm
not I don't know how to do that I didn't
go to college for that I don't even go
to college or nor do I know how to solve
problems like that if you was asking me
how to structure a joke I can help you
with that part but what you're talking
about right now I don't know I don't
know all I know is how to do my job
that's somebody else job I don't know
that I don't know cancer that was funny
but I want the other night right yes
hi Tiffany Wesley Messer from Good
Morning America hey Leslie you look
beautiful
thank you there's so much chatter online
about your dress with people saying that
it was no Maj actually to your family
yeah a little bit about why you picked
it and how you chose it well I had
talked to my stylist La Roche and and I
was telling him I want to wear something
that represents my father's country but
still has you know an American feel to
it something still stylish and
fashionable but still pays homage to my
heritage so this actually is the same
colors as the Eritrean flag and my
father's from Eritrea and then we found
a designer Pablo and bam he put it
together it's the only one that's out
there right now I'm wearing an original
this is really awkward for me I'm not
gonna lie nobody's paying attention
y'all typing this is rude if we was at a
comedy show right now I would because
then all of y'all out but it's cool I'm
waiting
I know y'all doing y'all job so any
other questions last one in the back
okay yes hi Tiffany Jamal Finkley black
tree TV hey we've been rocking for a
long time yes and I just wanna know like
how have you absorbed and moved on past
all the people that discount at your
career I'm not gonna name no names but
lately like how did how have you
absorbed that and use it to keep you
know keep your momentum going well first
off I don't absorb things like that
that's not good for my system I don't
absorb any type of negative
unless I'm gonna take use it to fire
back and I'm not gonna fire back at
something that's not worth firing back
at you know I love everybody I'll treat
everybody with kindness and respect and
I expect the same thing and if you can't
do it then I don't need to acknowledge
you thank you
Thank You Tiffany congratulations thank
you she ready